hello everyone
and welcome to today's webcast on
intelligent insights
into api security my name is manoj gunty
and i'm the product marketing manager
for
apigee at google before we begin with
cache i wanted to take this couple of
minutes to
cover some housekeeping items what you
see on your slide should resemble
the webcast console and at the bottom
left corner you will see a q a
console where you can post your
questions please note that you don't
have to wait
until the end of this webcast to post
your questions please feel free to post
them at any time during the webcast and
we will take 5-10 minutes
at the end of the webcast to go through
them next to the q a console is the
resources section
i will be making a lot of references to
some of the resources
during this webcast and links to all
those resources
will be available in the resources
sponsor for your reference
so let's get started we will begin this
webcast by talking a little bit
about the evolution of kpis and how
apis have evolved from being agents of
access
to powering digital transformation
efforts for several enterprises
and we will learn what this means for
operations teams in terms of added
pressure
and some of the challenges and we will
be introducing you today
to apigee's brand new feature called api
security reporting
we will learn about the key components
of this feature
and we will also do a deep dive demo
into the functionality
so apigee has been traveling with
several customers
along their digital journey and over a
period of time
we have seen apis evolving their role
within an enterprise
i.t systems if we take uh some of our
customers for example
equifax they have significantly
accelerated the time to market
of the new products and services by
leveraging apis and api programs
their partner onboarding time has
significantly reduced with the effective
use
of api programs and several companies
have built vast ecosystems of developers
and partners
using api programs ticketmaster for
example
is today selling tickets not only
through their own portal
but also they have they are leveraging
their partners using
apis to sell their tickets and improve
the overall fan
experience and digital companies
for example accuweather who has been a
customer of apigee for a long period of
time
has actually opened up a new revenue
stream using apis
today they are exposing uh key weather
data
through apis to external developers not
only through a developer portal
but also through third-party
marketplaces and
they are also making those apis
available for businesses to embed them
into their business applications and all
this is happening
through api programs and this has helped
them
unlock new revenue streams and open up
new markets
so as apis are powering innovation
across these
segments what does this mean for
operations teams
as you continue to power your business
critical applications
and services with apis there is an
increasing pressure on operations teams
to stay on top of them especially from a
security perspective
so some of the challenges that they face
today are
to gain complete visibility into the
security attributes of the apis
to ensure that whatever developers are
building
are compliant with the industry and
organizations compliance requirements
they also want to make sure that
whenever there is an
incident they want to know about that
incident even if it
impacts their business and if at all
there is an incident
and that is impacting they want to be
able to very quickly diagnose and
identify the root cause
of the issue so that they can take the
most
appropriate remedial actions and resolve
the issues
faster as far as as possible on the
other hand what is also happening
is as you build and scale your api
programs
there is the goldmine of api data that
is being collected on the backend
right and api management platforms like
apigee
have a great opportunity to leverage
this data
to actually help customers one
improve the availability and performance
of the apis
and number two to also ensure that the
apis are secure
and meet the compliance requirements so
across the entire value chain
all the way from your target back-end to
front-end consumers
there is this large amount of metadata
that rpg
is also collecting at the back-end so if
you look at the apigee api management
platform today
it is google cloud's comprehensive full
lifecycle aka management platform
which includes a runtime layer a
mediation engine
api analytics and also provides you a
developer portal
and monetization capability but the way
we are leveraging the api data today
is by providing three different kind of
metrics for three different personas for
somebody like a product manager
we provide developer engagement metrics
and for a business persona we are
looking at business metrics such as
revenue generation etc
and for an operations persona today we
have
a deep deeply integrated monitoring
capability
what we are introducing today is api
security reporting which is
a new added functionality which is also
leveraging the same api data
what we have seen in most of our
customers is that depending on the size
of the customer because depending on the
nature of their business
they have either an ops person looking
into the security attributes or there is
a set of
person dedicatedly looking at the
security attributes
so this feature essentially targets both
the
current i.t admin or or ops persona
and also the setups persona so let's
learn a little bit about this new
feature that we just had what is api
security reporting
it provides deep insights for operations
teams
to basically do three very important
things
one is to ensure that all the apis that
are being developed by the development
teams
are adhering to the security and
compliance requirements
number two is to ensure that the
sensitive data within the organization
is
not abused by internal or external users
and number three is when there is an
incident it provides you
the capabilities to quickly identify
and diagnose the root cause and quickly
take familial actions to solve it
let's get into each of these
functionalities in detail security
compliance
is essentially a functionality that
addresses
the design time governance of the
product
it is about ensuring that developers who
are the core power users of our platform
are building apis that incorporate all
the policies
required by the compliance team in many
cases
we have seen customers who think that
you know the
the apis that are being built are by
default
adhering to all the policies but only
when something breaks
they actually realize that that's not
the that's not the real that's not
really happening
on the field right and with this feature
users can quickly identify proxies
that do not that do not adhere to
traffic security
and extension policy requirements and
users will also be able to very quickly
review
what are the shade flow configurations
and revisions for each of those proxies
and you can also analyze which host
which virtual host and ports are open to
receiving
secure traffic as compared to unsecured
traffic
as we discussed earlier several
enterprises
are today powering business critical
applications
to apis so there is a lot of sensitive
data that gets actually
involved in this api for example
developer information
trace sessions api keys all of these are
attributes that are vulnerable for
vulnerable to abuse from internal and
external users
so with this new feature users can
very closely monitor who within your
organization
is actually accessing the sensitive
information
and if there are any anomalies in that
access pattern you can you can discover
or
detect those suspicious behavior apigee
by default provides or also provides
ways for you to extract information
outside of the platform through
management apis
and it becomes extremely critical for
the operations teams
to make sure to monitor those users who
are
actually extracting this data out of the
platform
so on top of all the logging
capabilities that
apigee offers today data protection
is one one additional feature that helps
you to
look at all the user activity that is
happening
inside your off and the third capability
that we brought up is
precision diagnosis physician diagnosis
essentially addresses the runtime
governance piece of the security
it gives users insights into
what percentage of traffic is secured
versus non-secure
and when there is an security incident
you can quickly analyze which apps are
causing causing those security incidents
and which back-end targets are actually
getting affected
because of that you can also identify
anomalies in traffic patterns identify
the root causes for those anomalies
and basically take the most appropriate
remedial actions to solve this
what is happening with this capability
is that a lot of
operations teams find it very useful in
terms of
overall reducing their overall mean time
to diagnose
an issue and also the mean time to take
remedial actions
so with that let's just take a quick
break from the slide
and actually go into the product and
take a quick demo of this
so this is the apigee api console and
if you go to the analyze section on the
left
menu just below the api monitoring which
we launched last year there
is api security reporting this is the
new feature
go to the overview page so uh there is a
functionality for users to actually
look at this from four different
timelines you can look at the last one
hour
last one day seven days and even thirty
days so let's look at the last seven
days data
so what you see at the first glance is
the northbound traffic
this is the traffic that is coming into
the rpg api platform
and you can see across different
environments
what are the number of proxies that are
deployed
what you see here as active proxies are
the
are the proxies that are actually
receiving traffic
and 16 is essentially the number of
processes that have been deployed
and against each of these environments
you can see
the amount of traffic that is coming in
and what is the percentage
change so if you kind of uh
predict that you know this kind of
change that you see
in this environment is something very
alarming
or it is it is uncommon then you can
quickly
look at the runtime reports and see
what's actually happening there
we will see that just in about a minute
you will also see the traffic
per region this is especially useful
for customers who have proxies deployed
across several regions
and when there is traffic coming from
the various
regions and when there is an security
incident
it will be very easy for the ops person
to look at the abnormalities
in a specific region and quickly drill
down into that region and see what
exactly
is happening okay and if you
have logged into this uh platform as an
org admin
what you will also see is user activity
and by the way this feature is available
only for the org admins you can quickly
see
who are the users that are accessing the
platform and this is for the time window
that we selected here which is seven
days
you will see the number of ui ui
pings and you will see the number of api
usage
and also see the change in the activity
and what is the sensitive operations
that they are accessed
let's learn a little bit about user
activity
so again i come to user activity i'm
selecting the last seven days data
so what you see here is list of all the
users
within this particular arc which is
selected who
have been accessing the arc for the last
seven days
and you can see at the number of logins
number of
ui operations and apis is essentially
the management apis
that have been accessed by users over
this period of time
and when there is a change in activity
you can see the abnormalities here
and this is where exactly you will see
the sensitive operations of the user
so what is sensitive operations the way
we have defined sensitive operations
is when a user is accessing information
that contains either developer
information
app information virtual host trace
sessions
or customer or custom reports and
let's say if there is one particular
user who has
who has accessed a lot of sensitive data
and if you feel that
this user is not supposed to be
accessing that
you can very quickly you know contact
that user and take the most
appropriate action
what we also have here is the compliance
page
this is the design time governance
aspect that i was talking about earlier
so here the first thing that you can do
is
look at the various environments and
select the right environment that you
want to look in
and then you will see the list of all
the proxies
as well as their relevant revision
number
against that and what you also see here
is the number of policies that have been
configured for each of these proxies
these policies include traffic policy
security policy as well as extension
policy
what you will also see is the number of
shade flows that are configured for each
of the proxies
and you will also be able to see whether
this particular proxy
has been receiving secure traffic https
versus unsecured traffic on non-https
and let's click on one of these and see
what additional information you can see
here so when you click on this
on the right hand panel you will also
see the details of the policies that
have con
that have been configured against these
policies
and on the shared flows you will
basically see
the list of all the shared flows that
have been configured
and when you select a shared flow you
will also see
the policies that are configured against
this particular
shared flow and what we also have
here is the target view
target view essentially will give you
information
about that particular whether the
receive secure traffic
versus non-secure traffic in several
cases
we have also seen that you know
customers have
realized that some of the targets have
been configured to receive
non-https traffic and after using this
feature in alpha they kind of very
quickly
were able to change the configurations
to ensure that
it receives only the secure traffic
and the third component that i want to
talk about
is runtime this is the runtime
governance aspect
and just like compliance you can also
select
you know the environment that you want
to look at
you can change the timeline here
and you can also select regions if you
have multi-regions
and look at the traffic that is flowing
into
each of these proxies so what you see
here is the traffic
over the selected period of time and the
percentage change
and what percentage is http request
versus non-https
you will also be able to quickly see
what are the apps that
are accessing this proxy and if there is
any abnormality
so let's take a situation and understand
this a little better
if there is a high percentage change
in the traffic that is coming to a
particular proxy
and i see i as an ops person i are as a
cops person
i understand that this is something that
is not supposed to happen
and that is coming mostly from a
non-secure
force then i will be very quickly able
to
understand which app is causing that
traffic
and once i know that i will be able to
take the most familiar actions
and to them to mitigate the damage that
is happening i can also look at
which target is actually being affected
because of that abnormality so this
kind of you know significantly reduces
the overall time to understand what is
going wrong
with that particular proxy and take the
most in the action
so that is that is all about the new
security reporting feature
that we launched if you have any further
questions please feel free to reach out
to us
and if you are not an apigee edge
customer please do download the free
trial and start using this
thank you so much for joining us and
have a nice rest
you